hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña santiago bilinkis él es
tecnólogo economista y emprendedor autor
del libro guía para sobrevivir al
presente atrapados en la era digital se
ha formado en estudios sobre
inteligencia artificial robótica
biotecnología e neurociencia y también
en nanotecnología es cofundador de
officenet y otros proyectos con él
abordaremos este presente hiper
tecnologizado en el que vivimos la
manera en la que nos controlan y
manipulan las redes sociales o
plataformas digitales y cómo nos
vinculamos con ellas santiago muchísimas
gracias por tu presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 en español
un gusto santiago plaza nuestra
abarcativa no el gusto es nuestro bueno
como decía en la introducción santiago
vivimos una vida muy tecnologizada
dedicamos una cantidad enorme de tiempo
y de atención sobre todo a las redes
sociales a las plataformas digitales de
hecho se estimula no se estima que
desbloqueamos el celular cada 6 minutos
y esto no es para nada casualidad
vosotros investigaste muchísimo no que
mecanismos y qué acciones hay detrás de
todo esto
bueno la primera cosa que es importante
entender cuando usamos redes sociales es
que nosotros no somos realmente los
usuarios cada uno cree que el objetivo
de las redes sociales es ponernos en
contacto por unos eso es lo que
denuncian ponernos en contacto por
nuestros amigos o seres queridos pero el
propósito de la red social dado cuál es
su modelo de negocio en realidad es
capturar nuestra atención a través de
nuestros amigos u otras cosas para
vender nuestro tiempo a sus anunciantes
y cuando uno entiende esto se da cuenta
que en realidad buena parte del uso
cotidiano está esta situación tan
habitual de que a cualquier lado que
vaya la gente está más pendiente de lo
que ocurre en su pantalla que de lo que
ocurre a su alrededor una casualidad las
redes tan increíblemente bien diseñadas
para hackear nuestra atención para
capturar nuestro tiempo y así tener el
mayor stock publicitario posible y quizá
el mayor problema es que los usuarios
las utilizamos con mucha ingenuidad si
vas a un negocio a comprar un producto
y cualquier producto uno siempre tiene
cierto grado de desconfianza si pregunta
si el precio será el precio correcto si
el producto será de buena calidad pero
cuando te ofrecen un producto gratis
como facebook como instagram como
youtube como el email 11 baja la guardia
y en realidad debiera ser exactamente lo
contrario si el producto es gratis
tendríamos que desconfiar el triple
porque querría una enorme empresa
multinacional gastar cientos de millones
de dólares en diseñar una red social una
plataforma de vídeos un sistema de
correo electrónico para que lo usemos
gratis dónde está la trampa o la trampa
es esa la trampa es que en definitiva
son gigantescos mecanismos de captación
de nuestro tiempo dándonos un servicio
que nos parece útil pero que en
definitiva está optimizado justamente
para que no podamos parar de usarlo
ahora y les entregamos muchísimo tiempo
no hablemos ahora de los mecanismos
psicológicos que permiten que nos
entreguemos de esa manera verdad en una
charla que hablaste sobre las
vulnerabilidades de la mente de las
cuales las redes bueno y plataformas
digitales se aprovechan y luego fuiste
consultado por esto no hiciste
referencia a algo muy interesante que
son los sesgos cognitivos nos podría
contar santiago que son cómo actúan
bueno la mente humana tiene muchas
fallas pero fallas no en el sentido de
que me equivoqué sino fallas
sistemáticas fallas predecibles fallas
en las cuales si yo diseño una situación
no te hago una pregunta de una
determinada manera puedo inducir la
respuesta esto que hasta hace poco era
relativamente desconocido algunos
científicos lo empezaron a usar
justamente para encontrar mecanismos de
manipulación y captura de la atención en
la universidad stanford hay un
laboratorio en la universidad stanford
en estados unidos hay un laboratorio se
llama el laboratorio de tecnología para
su así va cuya página web hasta hace
poco explícitamente decía que el
objetivo de este laboratorio era
estudiar cómo se podían utilizar las
aplicaciones móviles y las páginas web
para manipular los actos y los
pensamientos de las personas sea cómo
podemos usar las apps del celular para
cambiar lo que las personas piensan y lo
que las personas hacen y aunque suena
increíble somos extremadamente
vulnerables a esos mecanismos de
manipulación si no estamos alerta y no
sabemos justamente cuáles son esas
vulnerables las vulnerabilidades que
tenemos
para apareciera entonces por todo esto
que nos estás contando que no utilizamos
estas herramientas sino que quizá más
bien somos utilizados por ellas hay
trucos por llamarlo de alguna manera no
para los usuarios para quizás escapar de
esa manipulación o como lanzar quizás
una suerte de contraofensiva por decirlo
de alguna manera insisto
bueno todo empieza con las
notificaciones uno cree que en el
teléfono el propósito de las
notificaciones es valga la redundancia a
notificarnos pero no el propósito de las
notificaciones es distraernos es
interrumpir nos es cortar cualquier otra
cosa que estemos haciendo conversar con
una amiga una amiga desde jugar con
nuestros hijos trabajar enfocados eso no
le sirve a ninguna de las plataformas
entonces no se envía notificaciones
luminosas son horas o vibratorias para
distraernos y saber que hay algo que nos
estamos perdiendo y en nuestra cabeza
eso ya produce un pico de dopamina de
que será un neurotransmisor que ya nos
genera la curiosidad de qué estará
pasando en la red o en whatsapp por
cualquiera de estas plataformas que yo
me estoy perdiendo mientras pierdo el
tiempo jugando con mi hijo y esto es un
mecanismo muy fuerte es la primera
recomendación es que hay que apagar
todas las notificaciones del teléfono el
teléfono tiene que sonar no tiene que
encender luces ni tiene que vibrar así
es uno quién decide en qué momento lo
utiliza el segundo problema empieza
después
y es que tenemos la sensación de que
nosotros controlamos en conseguir
contenido que consumimos sin embargo hay
una estadística muy interesante que es
que 75% de los vídeos que se miran en
youtube son elegidos no por el usuario
sino por la propia plataforma en la
forma de una notificación saben
perfectamente bien cuál es el vídeo que
si nos avisan que está vamos a
interrumpir lo que estemos haciendo para
mirar por ejemplo el lanzamiento al me
gusta mucho la exploración espacial si
se está lanzando un cohete voy a dejarlo
lo que sea que esté haciendo para ver
ese lanzamiento y una vez que entramos a
la plataforma producto de la
notificación se activa el siguiente
mecanismo que es la recomendación de
vídeos excelentemente bien elegidos para
que nos paremos de mirar directamente el
auto play antes cuando terminaba de ver
un vídeo en youtube en netflix la
persona paraba uno tenía que elegir el
próximo ahora automáticamente apenas
termine el vídeo anterior comienza un
vídeo siguiente otra vez
increíblemente bien elegido de acuerdo a
lo que conocen de cada uno de nosotros
para maximizar la chance de que
continuemos mirando y así es como uno
entra en él a través de la notificación
pero después se queda a través de los
algoritmos de la inteligencia artificial
que en base a toda la información
personal elige el contenido
completamente ideal para capturar los
hablaba santiago de esa sensación de que
nos estamos perdiendo algo recién hacia
esto apunta a mi siguiente pregunta no
porque quisiera consultar te cómo
influye en nuestra autoestima las
comparaciones no al ver en red es algo
que sucede muchísimo nos vemos en redes
sociales imágenes de otras personas y
quizás uno tiene la sensación de que
somos las únicas personas del mundo con
una vida común con más problemas que
risas y que viaje es verdad y esto se
vincula quizás este concepto de formó no
fear of missing out que en español sería
el miedo a perderse algo esto genera
angustias ansiedad es verdad
absolutamente en una investigación que
hice el año pasado encontré que ésta
exista se está produciendo un
crecimiento vertiginoso de los
trastornos de ansiedad los ataques de
pánico y la depresión en todas en todos
los países del mundo expositiva en todas
las franjas poblacionales pero con mayor
fuerza aún en las mujeres adolescentes y
preadolescentes y esto tiene mucho que
ver porque uno de los mecanismos que las
redes sociales utilizan para captar
nuestra atención es explotar nuestra
curiosidad por espiar las vidas ajenas o
por impactar a los demás con nuestra
propia imagen entonces lo cierto es que
lo que se sube a las redes no es la
realidad nadie muestra ese momento
cuando recién se levanta que está de mal
humor todo despeinado no eligen al
elegimos el mejor momento de nuestra
semana sacado en el ángulo perfecto con
la luz mejor posible convenientemente
mejorado con filtros para que parezca un
mejor de lo que fue entonces es
inevitable que cuando uno empieza a
mirar la vida de los demás en las redes
y ve este espejo distorsionado este
espejo donde la vida de los demás parece
mucho mejor que la nuestra es inevitable
determinar sintiendo que somos como
decía somos los únicos que vivimos una
vida común más llena de problemas y
preocupaciones que de risas y puestas de
sol en instagram parece que están todos
navegando en el mediterráneo' y entonces
cuando vas en el colectivo en el tren en
el subte a trabajar a la mañana la
sensación es que todos los demás la
están pasando bien y eso es el único
pasándola mal eso tiene un impacto muy
fuerte sobre la autoestima ingeniera
este tipo de problemas de ansiedad
depresión y pánico santiago hagan una
analogía muy interesante que has
planteado en varias oportunidades es una
comparación que hace es no entre el
consumo de comida chatarra y las redes
sociales podría desarrollarla para
nuestra audiencia
bueno seguramente recordarán que cuando
apareció la comida chatarra no la
llamábamos comida chatarra la llamamos
comida rápida traducido del inglés fast
food
y era medio aspiracionales porque no
quería ir a comer esa comida y en algún
momento cambiamos la mirada y le
cambiamos el nombre y pasa a conservar
la comida chatarra otras
porque porque está bien puede ser rápido
a la parte de rápida es muy poco
saludable no dejamos de comerla pero
sabemos que está mal entonces yo no va a
comer una hamburguesa en una de estas
cadenas o pollo frito sabe que se está
dando un gusto que puede ser rico a
corto plazo pero no es bueno para
nuestra salud de largo plazo bueno con
el contenido digital pasa algo parecido
sólo que todavía no cambia nuestra
mirada 'tik tok' es el pollo frito de la
mente podemos darnos el gustito media
hora por día de mirar algo que nos
cautiva nos distrae y no nos aporta nada
demasiado nutritivo pero no puede ser la
base de nuestra alimentación digital no
puede ser yo porque así como nuestro
cuerpo está hecho de la comida que
comemos si comemos mucha comida grasosa
nos sube el colesterol nuestra mente
está hecha del contenido digital que
consumimos si no la pasamos mirando
vídeos virales en una de estas
plataformas eso afecta mucho cómo
funciona nuestra mente y nuestra
información y nuestra conexión con los
demás hablemos ahora de un sector en
particular de la población niñas y bebés
que han sido descubiertos como target
consumidor también verdad ante quizás
apuntaba más a su padre en madre pero
ahora se apunta directamente a ellos no
santiago y de hecho hay madres padres
que muestran como destrezas no esta
utilización temprana que hacen sus hijos
e hijas de las tecnologías pero qué
consecuencia tiene esto en las infancias
bueno este es un problema gigante porque
todas las asociaciones pediátricas del
mundo están recomendando que los menores
de 2 años no tengan ningún tipo de
acceso a dispositivos digitales pero la
realidad corre completamente por otro
carril no y el mayor problema de esto es
cuan extremadamente funcional es esto a
los adultos a carlos y ahora que estoy
hablando con vos tuviera a mi cuidado un
nene una nena de un año y medio bueno si
necesito que no me interrumpa le doy un
autito y a los dos minutos ya se aburre
y viene a buscarme de nuevo si le doy
una muñeca se ahora a los tres minutos
pero si le doy un celular a una tablet a
ese nene o esa nena va a estar dos horas
entretenidos sin interrumpirme y es más
cuando dentro de dos horas quiera
recuperar el aparato no me lo va a
querer dar y va a ser toda una escena de
berrinche para seguir utilizándolo y
este es el mismo mecanismo que
hablábamos antes contenido
increíblemente bien diseñado y
seleccionado para capturar la atención y
después no poder no soltarla esto es
especialmente serio
niños y niñas de edades muy tempranas
pero de nuevo esto es muy cómodos los
adultos a cargo y entonces cada vez más
adultos recurren el chupete electrónico
a estos dispositivos capaces de
entretener y neutralizar por decirlo de
alguna manera a los chicos mientras los
adultos necesitamos hacer nuestras cosas
muchas veces usar las redes sociales
deben estar presos de este mismo
mecanismo
santiago bilinkis muchísimas gracias por
esta entrevista ha sido un placer
un gran placer santiago siempre a
disposición gracias a ti nuevamente a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a que
sigan informando en france 24 y en
france mit y cuatro.com sigan con
nosotros
[Música]